relational algorithms from the
perspective of the algorithms Community
truth is I did not really like realize
the potential benefit of this program
until started basically try toiz this
relational algorithm day and we started
realizing like this connect in
terminology so hopefully we will be able
to talk the same language understand
each other better after uh this
program yeah so there's two uh you know
couple things here one is I want to go
sort of give my take on the some of the
things mud did and then I want to um
talk about some uh additional algorithm
design technology so just recall
relational algorithms are algorithms
that are efficient if the inputs in
relational
form um so just as an analogy um you can
imagine trying to search for a string in
a compressed text okay so one way to do
that is uncompress the text and then
search do your standard search sech
algorithm um but the problem then is you
have to pay the cost of uncompressing
the text okay so uh there's algorithms
in the literature about searching
directly on
compressed uh strings without you know
having to do the decompression and
that's sort of analogously the same
thing here like when the data is stored
uh in relational tables the data is
compressed and you'd like to avoid the
cost of decompressing it um so what are
the take a put way points that I that I
want to get across particularly to the
algorithms people um this is an
interesting uh algorithmic area
um that's
uh not received much attention and since
my PhD student who's working in this
area left I've sort of paused and I
would it' be great if somebody else
wanted to work on this with me um
there's presumably lots of interesting
open problems but uh
uh you know if you're going to work in
this area you have to put some work into
finding the open problems um so you need
sort of do it's not like fruit picking
it's like
mining so yeah so
um sort of this relational algorithms
model is a kindred spirit to other
restricted computational models for like
the MPC model or the streaming model
where uh with the AL algorithm can do is
more restrictive than say your standard
Ram model so a lot of the times the the
the secret to success in these areas is
being able to find problems that you can
solve in these restricted models like if
you just take your average problem out
of clrs and try to solve it in these
models it's just too complicated you
need to look at simpler
problems all right all right so here's
you know if you were an algorithms
person and wanted to get started in this
area here's the things I think think you
need to know to get
started um I'm just going to go through
these so first you have to know what a
joint is so you know there's a couple
ways about thinking about a joint is one
is you can sort of think about if you're
joining two tables you can kind of think
about them as bipartite graphs two
different bipartite graphs and the
variables that you're joining it
on um you sort of identify those two so
so then what you're doing in the join is
these two hot packs that you get all
right um another way of thinking about
what a joint is and the way that I sort
of like is
geometrically so you can think about the
join as points in some higher
dimensional
space okay and what happens you know if
I take the join of axy and B YZ and then
project back to
XY well I get exact ly my original table
axy okay and if I join axy with bxy and
project down to the the plane YZ I get
back to my original table B
YZ okay so one way to think about this
are these are points that are stored by
their projections into lower dimensional
spaces but this is actually not always
true because in a you might have
dangling that do not CH with B so after
you do the join and project we might get
okay all right so again but this is sort
of a way to think about what's going on
there's some things I'm going to say
that are
oversimplifications um but that's sort
of the way that I like to think about
these things
um all right
um good
um so you know here's sort of a a table
of you you know some of the research in
this area and you have Sitting on Top
some problems which relational
algorithms have been developed for uh in
the red or you some find some
algorithmic techniques but the key point
to take away here is everything rests on
these Su product queries every algorithm
we know at the Bas is somehow using some
product queries okay um
so we you know in some sense we don't
know how to do anything that's not
that's not based on a some product query
so uh let me go back and review some
product queries and the first thing I'm
going to do is just change mood's
definition of what a su product query is
I'm going to throw away the
tables I'm going to abstract out the
tables okay so for me a sum product
query is you're taking a sum over the
rows of the
join and then you're taking a product
Over The Columns of some function of
that
entry
okay uh so for example okay so like What
are problems you s to take this
geometric
view
of of you know what the joint is so you
know it's points in higher dimensional
space so like What are problems you
might try to develop algorithms for any
geometric problem where the input is a
collection of
points all right so for example one
geometric problem is how many points are
in the
input right you would not find that in
any in any geometric algorithms book why
because it's too
simple right I mean you wouldn't even
teach that in a cs1 course but if the
points are in compact representation
that it's interesting you know what
point is farthest from the origin K
means for example those are all you know
problems for the input is
points
um so all right so let's consider the
problem of how many points are in the
input okay if you have an explicit
listing this is
Trivial uh if the input's in relational
form it's just NP hard to decide whether
the list of points is empty or
not okay uh it's sharp P hard to count
the number of points in the input right
so that would seem to be a negative
result but at the end of the day we
don't really
care
right you know we want to sort of do our
algorithm in terms of su product queries
and if the structure of the table is
very complicated that's somehow not
that's not the fault of our Su product
or our algorithm our relational
algorithm that's that's the fault of
whoever designed the tables yes which
form be to decide if the input is not
empty what would be the form if the
tables are are relations and you want to
know whether the join of the tables is
not
empty uh any arbitrary number of Jo yes
um so okay good but so how can I write
this as a sum product query well I just
sum up over the
rows of the product Over The Columns of
one for each column right this is sort
of a trivial sum product query so you
know for this table over here I'd have
eight sum ANS each of them is 1 Time 1
time one because there's three columns
all right so now that I have that I can
now feed it to the you know the variable
elimination algorithm that sort of sits
beneath that but I don't need to worry
about that once I have a sum product
query like that's that'll be the base of
my
algorithm all right how about if you
want to know the the the furthest point
from the origin say in the the two Nome
squared well okay so then
I uh you know this is again the tropical
semi- ring that you saw in mood's talk I
take the max over every row of the sum
of the squares of the
columns okay so for this particular
table it' be the max of 32 + 1 s + 7^ S
or 3 S + 1+ 8 squ and I take the max
over all of those and that'll give give
the
answer all right so that's a su product
query and that sort of can be that I can
do that as a as a base operation of my
algorithm all right so now I want to uh
give some examples of using some CTIC
queries to develop
algorithms all right and I'm going to
use as a running example K means
clustering it's the classic algorithmic
problem so the input for this problem
consists of a bunch of points and an
integer
K and what I want to do is and I want to
find K points that in some sense
represent the the X's well that or
summarize them well in some
sense so I want to find three points
these three red points here S1 S2 S3
such that if I look at the distances
from all the blue points to their
nearest Red Point that's
minimized so the aggregate distance okay
and I'm going to use the two Norm
squared distance so the normal distance
squared all right good so now when we're
desiging relational
algorithms you know we we sort of
developed the following strategy there's
a plan A and A Plan B and a plan C so
plan a is if there's already an
algorithm out there that's algorithm
right that's the standard algorithm can
you relate that Implement that algorithm
in a relational way so what does it mean
to implement in a relational aray you
could produce the same output that that
algorithm does but maybe you compute it
differently okay but the the output is
the same as the standard
algorithm Plan B is
um you know is okay I can't Implement
that
algorithm but I'm going to implement
another algorithm that gets whatever the
guarantee is that the original algorithm
got so if the original algorithm was you
know four approximate or something I
will try to design another algorithm
that's also four approximate or maybe
five approximate or
something but it has sort of has the
same guarantee so if you were happy with
the the standard algorithm you should be
happy with this one and then plan C that
didn't work you know well what can you
do can we do something can we do
something
weaker
right so um what what are some of the K
means Al so one k means algorithm is K
means
Plus+ um which is the most cited paper
to ever appear in soda
apparently um but what this says is you
pick the next center with probably
proportional to its distance to the
nearest previously picked center right
so if you have some point that's very
far from all the previous centers
probably you're likely to pick that one
you're more likely to pick that
one um
and one things we discussed over beer
last night was that one cultural
difference between the database guys and
the algorithms guys is we don't put
randomized algorithms up randomized
algorithms are real algorithm to us um
so I didn't even bother to put
randomized algorithms all right
um so you know another algorithm in the
literature is this adaptive K means
algorithm um
and you know if you try you can prove
that if you you know to be able to
implement this algorithm to be able to
compute the same output that this
algorithm does even if the tables are
very simple is EMP be hard right so it's
not reasonable to expect that you can
Implement exactly this
algorithm so then what did we do we had
to go to plan
B Plan B was okay I'm not going to
compute exactly the same weights that
this algorithm does I'm going to compute
alternate weights but those alter
alternate weights give me the same
theoretical guarantee as the original
weights can you explain
what the sentence in plan means what is
how would this imply what is the
technical result behind this okay so a
problem is you know NP hard if you have
a polinomial time algorithm for it you
know if you give a polom so you know the
input to this problem would be your a
relational representation of of points
in high dimensional space and the output
would be the weights that this other
algorithm produces right so if you you
know we're a if you're able to produce
those weights then we're able to you
know somehow we're able to reduce
satisfiability to producing those
weights so if you could if I knew it
those weights were then I could decide
whether formula is
satisfiable sure but understand that but
the nor relation implementation how does
it avoid the speed for the non
regulation because it's doing so it has
an explicit listing of the points ah
okay so it's Inc presentation again yeah
so everything the hardness comes from
the fact that there's this compact
representation and sometimes so first
off if the compact representation is
very complicated there's nothing you can
do right if you just want to know is the
joints empty or not that's NPR right so
our our our usual assumption when we
start is
that you know the tables aren't
complicated but even if the tables
aren't complicated it's still could be
complicated to compute some things on
them does it mean for this hardness
result hard for non
communicated yes so we have I don't
remember exactly but it could be for
example that the tables are just a cross
product
joint I don't remember exactly what the
structure is but there's some structure
of the tables so you look at them and
say okay those are
not you you can't say that the structure
of the table is G like if you look at
the structure of the table where the
proof NP hardness to decide whether the
joint is empty or not those tables
clearly encode a sad
instance all
right all right so
um so there's okay so now there's sort
of plan A B and C you know once you
decide
um what you're going for they sort of I
kind of broke you know maybe I'm trying
to find it a relation algorithm that has
the same approximation guarantee it's a
standard algorithm there's sort of three
different levels of approaches first if
you can just write the problem as a some
product query you're done right um the
second is to sort of try to design
something from scratch so you're trying
to you know like it's not obviously a
some product query but maybe I can in
some non-obvious way write it as a non
as a some prodct query and then our
strategy is instead of trying to do
it um for arbitrary you know sort of in
arbitrary career we sort of have a
warmup first we try a cross product join
and then we try a path join and then we
try to generalize it um and then C is
you just uh you know it's the standard
thing you you've already built up a
bunch of things you know how to do with
some product queries and you just you
know try to use those all right so let's
talk about one means
Plus+ so one means Plus+ just means you
want to pick a point uniform at random
from the from the input
points um so one thing you can do do is
is sort of reduce uniform uh generation
to Counting You Can Count then you can
uniformly generate things so if you look
at so this is our our Su product query
at the bottom that
counts okay so if you you uh go look at
the implementation of that what the
variable elimination scheme will give
you at the end so all right so let me
back up a little bit
so um so let's think about this on a
path query okay so a path query means
that I'm I'm joined together tables with
two attributes per table and you know
that the second attribute of one table
is equal to the first attribute of the
next table so if I join these these four
tables together this is like I have a a
layer graph with five
layers so you know what would the uh the
counting problem here would be to count
how many paths I have from the first
layer to the last layer okay um if you
do that you know what this variable
elimination algorithm will'll end up
with at the end is you'll end up with a
count for each you know each of this
vertex at the end how many paths do I
have ending up there right so uh you
know the the number of paths I have
ending up or feature or attribute five
is one is there's four of them right so
now if I have these numbers four four
and one one I can do uniform generation
right I pick with probably four nths I
pick I pick a uh a point where the the
fifth attribute of the fifth features
one and I just go backwards and do
that all right so all right that so you
know
the the implementation of one means plus
plus is just a su product you know sort
of the reduction from uh uniform
generation to counting and then using a
some prodct query
um all right the second one is two means
plus
plus can I ask a question sure go
forward so why is it trivial once you
count to sample because you want to
sample from your relational inst right
you don't have EXC
representation yes but I know in my if I
joined it
together right there would be nine rows
in the join yes right and four of them
would end up with feature attribute 5 is
equal to
one right so if I
picked conceptually I pick one of the
rows that has uh one is the fifth
attribute with probably 49es I've I've
haven't made a mistake right I'm I'm
doing toward uniform
sampling right and then you sort of have
to trace this back this it's like
for I mean I think of all this in terms
of shortest path right so like if you
want to find the shortest path you just
sort of trace it back where did where
did I come from and
it's
theate
yes all right
good all right so
now um so now I want to do two Norms
Plus+ and I want to pick a point with
probably for proportional to its two
Norm distance from the uh uh the
previously picked Point okay um so now
I'm G again want to
reduce uh uniform or uh uh random
sampling to Counting so what I need to
do is I need to count theh two aggregate
two Norm squared of the
points um so again here if I do the same
thing uh if I look at uh uh
the sum of the two Norm squared for the
all the points in the join with the
fifth attribute is one I'll get 32 if I
haven't done the math right okay so then
I can you know pick out a point where
the fifth attribute is one with probably
32 over 32 plus 44 plus 45 and do the
same all right
um
good all right
so how am I going to compute the two
Norm
squared okay so as a warmup let's look
at the the the a path
query okay so again I I want to compute
this the sum of the squares of the of
the attributes on the path so just just
think about an edge here going from y to
Z right and I'm extending my sum when
I'm at y to Z right right so how what is
my sum of the squares at Z going to be
well it's all the things all the sum of
the squares up to Y plus there's going
to be some y squar terms I have to add
to it well how many y squar terms I'm
going to have to add I'm going to have
to add the number of Y squar terms is
the number of paths that ended you know
end at
y
right and then the number of paths that
go to Z is the number of paths that that
go to Y number of paths that go to Z
Plus number of paths go to Y previously
went to
Z all right so you know what does that
suggest is the two things that I need to
know are the sum of the squares and
number of paths like this is the you
know this is like an
undergraduate algorithm so now how do I
go to a su product
query so um the two things I'm going to
need to know what are the the elements
of the of the base set of my semi- ring
there's going to be
pairs okay one's going to count the
number of paths and one's going to be
the sum of the
squares
okay and now you know when I do a
variable elimination algorithm think
about trying to eliminate this variable
y
here right so for the moment think about
doing shortest path right you want to
compute the shortest path to Z right and
this is you know given given this
information here well it's either the
shortest path you had to Z before or
that's the is path to a plus y s like
that's the standard relax operation and
all of the you dtra bment for it or
whatever so we want to do the same thing
here where Min is is the is the semi-
ring sum and addition is the semi- ring
product right so I've just
Rewritten you know Rewritten up on this
line as I just you know change uh Min to
plus and uh to semi- ring plus and
addition to semi ring multiplication and
then you want to get you know this is my
new
answer okay this is you know the number
of the number of paths should sum and
then the sum of the squares should you
have to add N na a copies of Y
squ so my goal is then I need to design
a semi- ring plus and a semi- ring
product so that this this gives me the
answer that I want
right so then if you play around this
for a while
um turns out that this is the right
thing to do okay in in the semi- ring
addition I want to add both components I
want to add the sums and I want to add
the numbers and in the product I take
the product of the first coordinate and
somehow something like the cross product
of the second coordinate or something
like that okay and uh you know with that
you multiplicative idty one zero and the
addtive Z Z and if you go plug that in
it does what you want it gives you the
right answer
okay but you know I designed this semi-
ring from sort of looking at this you
know looking at it in the pathway of
looking at
it all right um so I found I found this
interesting when I was doing this is
that
um um you
know certain some product queries you
can sort of solve with dynamic
programming so for example shortest path
is a su product query and and and
Bellman Ford's a dynamic programming
algorithm that solves shortest
path turns around that the other is true
as well like I can Implement some
Dynamic
programs as a some product query which I
did not know
beforehand and and kind of roughly
speaking you know what is the base of
the semi- Ring the base of the semi-
ring is like a row in your Dynamic
program okay okay so then when you're
when you're sort of doing these sums and
the products you are combining these
rows and dynamic programs so that when
you're done in some sense it's
conceptually be the answer that your
Dynamic program
got I'm not going to be able to get into
this this is sort of in too much detail
but I just wanted to sort of point this
out because this is somehow you know a
step toward dynamic programming so now
the you know the base of my semian is
structured data
here
[Music]
all right
um all right so now on to three three
means Plus+ so now I want to select my
third
Center um with
uh distance
proportional to its distance to the
nearest of the two previous
centers okay so if you know say I picked
this S1 and this S2 of my two previous
centers if I look at the separating
line um I want to pick the green points
that are to the lower left of the
separating line with probability
proportional their distance to S1 and I
want to pick the points up and to the
right of the separating line probably
proportional their distance to
S2 so now you know how did we do this
the last example we sort of reduced this
to summing up these these
distances um now turns out that this is
you know we can construct this is NP
hard we can construct sort of simple
tables simple instances where if I can
compute the aggregate distances to the
line from these points that would that
would you know give you an algorithm for
your favorite NP hard problem so
therefore we can't do this trick that we
did last time of reducing random uh
generation to something that just that's
not going to
work all right
so we need a plan
B
um and the idea is to use rejection
sampling okay um so the idea of
rejection sampling is you can
use uh you know you have a hard there's
a hard distribution you'd like to Le
from um but you can't do that so what
you do is you try to find an easy
distribution that in some sense is close
to the hard distribution and then try to
sample from that okay so this is the
standard example maybe you want to
uniformly uh sample from the blue circle
circles are kind of complicated maybe
that's hard so what you could do is
uniformly sample from the red square and
then if it's outside of the circle you
can decide whether points in or outside
the circle then you could reject the
points that are outside the
circle right that would end up giving
you a uniform sample from the blue
circle and if the you know the area of
the blue circle and the area of the Red
Square are relatively close you
shouldn't need too many samples until
you get something from the the blue
circle as be relatively efficient K can
you go back a slide sure okay so I had
been trying to think about this is just
like okay I can just think about dynamic
programming
as um you know my branching step is you
know I I can I can Branch if I have you
know like the right additive structure
for the semi- ring and then within each
sub piece I just need to find the right
like multiplicative structure for the
semi ring what you're actually saying
here is that that isn't everything
because it can be NP hard to do like
when I'm looking at the compact
representation it's NP hard sometimes to
do that branching
step so I don't know what that branching
step is I mean like my recursive step in
my Dynamic
program
um so I don't know what dynamic program
you're talking about here I mean this is
uh I mean this is just your standard you
know ND completeness proof for whatever
you have
to okay so it has nothing to do with I
me there's no algorithm here I mean I
just you know show that your favorite
problems NP complete you show how to you
know take your favorite NP complete
problem construct an instance of this
where the the answer would tell
you you know you answered your your
favorite complete problem
okay maybe I in retrospect maybe I
should have put one of these reductions
up here but they are really they really
just if you know how to do NP
completeness proofs you can do this yeah
yeah there's nothing else going on okay
okay all
right good so how do we do this so
what's uh all right so this is just more
rejection
sampling
um so you know con conceptually we uh
you know take the space and divide it
into sort of three parts one is we put a
box around
S2 one is we put an axis parallel box
around S1 and then there's the points
that are outside of either box okay
and um
I guess the key fact is the points that
are outside of either box are roughly
equally close to either Center the
points that are very close to one of the
two centers are in the
Box okay so then um what is our
distribution that we sample from uh if
it's if it's in if the point is in box
B2 we use the distance to S2 and if it's
outside of box B2 we use the distance to
as
one okay now
um so now you know
uh yeah so now what can go wrong um you
know if we s if we if we end up sampling
a point that's sort of on the left Sor
on
the yeah so we if we end up sampling a
point that's up into the right of the
purple but outside of box two we got the
distance
wrong right because we we used the
distance to be one and we didn't use the
distance to B
two okay but those are close right so
you know okay we just reject it with
some probability you know that has to do
with the ratio of the distance from to
to S1 and S2 and we just try again but
that's because they're closed that'll
only happen half the time or
something all right
um good so if we look at your sum
product
query
um yeah so this is the these are these
individual individual
um skip that all right um so the
conclusion is uh you know even though
it's it's it's NP hard to do the sum we
can use we can use rejection sampling
because can find a distribution we can
sample from using some product queries
as
Clos what's the next
one all right so the next
one
uh that I that uh I wanted to talk about
is counting the number of points in a
hypersphere
um
so
um all right so this is this is to do
this this is an example of uh the thing
that M mentioned at the end which is a
sum product query with a constraint
right so what do I want to do I want to
count all the points in the hypersphere
so that the my Su product query is just
my standard counting query count the
points but now I only want the points in
the hypersphere right so I have a
constraint here I should only accept
those points that lie in the
hypersphere all right
so
uh so in general uh solving some product
queries even with a single constraint is
end be hard but a lot of times we can
approximately solve the sum product
query within a factor of 1 plus Epsilon
as long as our semi- ring
has you know some structure that the
operations are approximation preserving
okay which mostly means not
subtraction okay you just need if I
approximate these two things and apply
the operation to them the result will be
an approximation of the exact you know
product and then approximating which is
not true of subtraction but it's true of
all the other standard operations that
we've seen today all right so you know
as a special case I can count the points
in the hypersphere centered at the
origin using this Su product query with
an additive
inequality okay and the algorithm for
doing this is again implementing a
dynamic program which I didn't want to
go into so s you're saying inquality
because on the left is some or it's you
you it's you know it looks like a linear
inequality but the things you're adding
up don't have to be linear so here I'm
summing up the squares of the
entries all right um so again just the
the takeaway
points you know this is this is
potentially an interesting area if
you're willing to put in some but you
know the the initial the initial start
is we have to find some problems um you
know what are some if you wanted If
you're sort of interested this uh and
you want to come back at too what are
some things that you might discuss well
um one thing is just what would be some
interesting geometric problems to think
about right what something that's easier
than the you know that your
normal sort of your your
normal geometric problems that are that
that you know that might be interesting
to develop a relational algorith for and
then we also have
like a homework problem so the when I
onboard people into research
particularly students rather than have
them read papers I like to give them
homework problems so they can discover
the basics themselves so we have a lud
and I came up with a homework problem um
which is implement the standard ID3
decision tree algorithm so I'm going to
just tell you a little bit about that
now so that we can hit the ground
running uh when we get when we get here
at
two so you know imagine that I
have my table it's this is a supervised
learning problem so I have a table and
one of the columns is a label which
tells me whether this is a positive or
negative
instance
okay and I'm you know I'm trying to
build a decision tree uh that help me to
help me do classification but I don't
really need to do this here understand
this here so
um I can think of my table having an
entropy so it's the standard binary
entropy function on the fraction of of
table entries that have uh a zero label
and the uh the fraction of entropies
that have a one label right so that's a
binary variable it has an
entropy okay so here a third of the the
tables a third of the entries are zero
so the the binary entry be be 1/3 time
log 3 plus 2/3 time log
three right so the the the core of the
ID3 algorithm is to find a comparison
that gives you the most
information okay if I you know uh uh uh
you know about what whatever the you
know about the label of of what I'm
asking a question about or or
equivalently that the resulting
conditional entropy be minimized right
if I the resulting conditional entropy
went to zero then you know i' I've
completely learned what I need to
learn so for example if I have this
table uh one possible comparison is a u
Lesson
Four right so if I so that would sort of
maybe be the rot of my decision tree so
now what would be the resulting uh
conditional entropy of U Lesson Four
well two thirds of the entries are less
than four so it'd be 2third of the
entropy of the of the entries that are
less where you is less than four plus
onethird of the entropies of the entropy
of the entries where you is greater than
four so for example the conditional
entropy When U is less than four I have
three entries that are one and one to
entry zero so it' be 1/4 log four plus
34 log 43 right so the algorithmic
problem is find that comparison right
that that gives me that that minimizes
this conditional
entropy right um and you know there's
multiple there you know sort of a a good
warm-up problem because there's a base
obvious algorithm that just uses um some
product queries and then you you sort of
think about this there's like you know
there's a slightly more efficient
algorithm that requires a slightly more
uh sophisticated understanding of some
product queries um but this is a good
warm-up problem so this will be you know
this would be one option for this
afternoon all right so I gu I went
through that a little quicker than I
thought so uh but I don't think anybody
will object going to lunch early um any
questions specifically any questions
about the homework
problem block
session go for so I have a question
about the uh
the so that basically you encod it as a
some product right so they maret it's a
path as long as you have a Simplicity
then you get so I can just write it as a
su product query whether the the table
is very sck like or Not by my the way I
view the world is not my
problem that's database guys problem was
just an example right so basically what
you can actually what what's happening
is that you can some product your TBL
and then whatever strcture Rel have that
will affect yeah so my advice to the
algorithms guys and maybe the database
guys is solve the problem on the path
query because we like graph algorithms
right we teach graph algorithms for 20
years I'm happy with graph algorithms
solved the graph
problem once you understand that usually
it just Maps over to
some some product query relatively
simply okay so getting ISS what is the
right and
that yeah I mean so for the example with
the sum of the squares I realized on a
graph you know this is the basic
algorithm homework problem count the sum
of the squares of the link you know
links I know how to do this I need to
keep I need generalized recursion to
keep track of both the number of paths
and the sum of the squares and then then
I can design you know once I know that
that's what I need to keep track of then
I can design my sem
R so that's Apparently one Gap in
communication between the database
versus the algorithms people is that
apparently the algorithm people preper
to
uh use shouldest b as the origin of
everything and measure everything in
terms of it so welcome to the last three
years of my life yeah he's always saying
oh it's matrix multiplication I'm always
saying oh no it's shortest path
so could you want to tell everyone the
exact time you have for the afternoon
okay good so the plan for the afternoon
is uh we're gonna show up it too noer is
gonna put two of her problems up here
I'm gonna put
the relational de uh algorithms up here
so there'll be three things I'm going to
split you into the three you pick go
stand by the problem you're interested
in and then we will split those groups
up like so you know there's 15 people
over here who want to work on no ver 12
cycle problem then we'll split those 15
people up into three groups of five
where they're not all databased people
or not all those people go talk give us
feedback how it worked today and then
we'll decide tomorrow if you're much
Happ with open problems and you you
hated this and we'll do that tomorrow if
you love this we might do it again
tomorrow it's sort of a day to day
thing yeah so we split people into K
into clusters using K
means all right enjoy your
[Applause]
lunch